[Music]
this sword is so sharp it cuts the meme
in half
oh yeah oh yeah this sword is so sharp
ow it's not sharp at all you can
literally see the edge
which is probably for the best with the
way i'm handling this
so thank you for not giving me a super
sharp sword
it's nice however you don't want to [ __ ]
with
don't report the video it was a joke i'm
sorry prin uh goddammit
you realize that you are the only ones
with the resources to compete with
youtube when it comes to creator content
driven media
please make us a safer work site and
save us from this youtube nightmare
the last bastion of hope a literal porn
site
did something happen i'm confused what
is this
perks power up unlock perks
buy a monthly power up subscription
what's all this thing
become a hero everyone a hero become a
hero the pewdiepie is subreddit
pewdiepie my hero he's really nice felix
viking ancestor seeing him speaking
english as his first language
living in the uk playing with the katana
saying that he misses japan
don't do me like this man bro why do you
think the vikings invaded everything
huh because they didn't like where they
stayed if they were happy and content
where they were
they wouldn't [ __ ] around with everyone
else's [ __ ] right if anything i'm
available like yeah dummy you guys don't
understand vikings like i do
another celebrity ruined by drugs guys
check out branding i don't understand
how i still don't get how it works
and what does it say ken in the
background ken has always been in the
background
it's like that thumbnail meme oh my god
i don't even like pie die pie oh yeah
it's all coming to get it
i finally saw this movie the other day i
never seen it emperor's new group
it's great i liked it i probably would
have liked it more as a child
but i still enjoyed it oh i was thinking
about this i should do a photoshop
video this week yeah i'm definitely
doing that early
in the morning i like that
i like the constant skin transplant he
does to make this happen
that's how you know it's going to be a
demon
[Laughter]
that's a big scene so time to grind
beautiful i'm sorry felix i have sinned
now no no
you've done well let me kiss your
forehead
very good very good me after pewdiepie
downloads my meme with the downvote i
could not create
that
that's gotta hurt but not as much as the
pain
of me cutting your actual pp logo
can we get a 3d print and i'll cut it
that'd be sick
let's get it maybe making bamboo dammit
even if school taught you how to do
taxes and get a job you still wouldn't
listen in class
[Laughter]
it's a great meme i've never seen yeah i
like it big peepee
doesn't relate to me at all but that's
the rules hey that's a huge
[ __ ] dick i like it
man arrester excuse me
excuse me hold up guys just gotta take
care of something
what did he do he put down fake social
distancing arrows in ikea creating a
labyrinth we know x
sounds like a horror game yeah it's
already confusing enough you make it
more confusing and people are trapped in
eternity me reading my own post every
time someone likes it
yup seems about right elon musk new chip
will allow you to transmit music
directly to
the brain without use of headphones
hackers crack the chip
pewds
[Music]
i have a knife now there will be no more
rickrolls do you understand me
okay you don't [ __ ] with me this meme
was dead
let it be dead all right from now on i'm
downloading all rick rolls they're not
funny
stop it pewds when he opens reddit
[Music]
yeah pretty much it except i'm not doing
this anymore
you guys are gonna have to come up with
something more clever oh by the way
speaking of more epic
and clever and sexy yeah i said it next
week
jacksepticeye will host lawyer with me
we've never had a guest lawyer before so
please make your memes
related to that he gave you up oh good
good
good good good good
good i received 25 you received
years of fun mojang i received 25
and also really shitty realm servers
that actually doesn't work a lot of the
times
and you have to pay a monthly
subscription for it
that's where microsoft came in didn't
they hey pewds here's the total mother
i'm dying in case you get rick rolling
the next friday would be pewdiepie
oh thank you thank you so much
i have a knife i don't need all right
sorry i need this stuff hey dude i know
you're swedish and all but you
thought i'd let you know there's a rumor
going on around that you're stuck on
these
[Music]
i'll skin a duck okay i'll skin him
it will happen it's gonna die you're
dead dolan
just saw a video of felix hitting
mcdonald's in india
is it good how it tastes i want to know
do they have pie average katana fan
average european longsword enjoyer
i do enjoy a good longsword not gonna
lie
what's that [ __ ] one from dark souls
swyhander
the [ __ ] swyhander hell yeah
look at these bad boys hell yeah
ah that has fine diner i swear
ah very good we can put a try hider
together
oh yeah peter peter
is that's my german
okay the power of branding hey
someone gets it all right this is
perfect because i get to call this out
on [ __ ] tick tock
this garbage ass side they keep calling
out these chairs right they're like oh
they're so uncomfortable but this would
be no okay you have to understand
it's not just branding when you buy a
pewdiepie chair you're also buying
premium quality
italian leather this is the greatest
chair i've ever sat on
oh that's kind of cute thanks for the
copyright
has basic human interaction with a
female in front of my dad
him
go get him son you got this when pewds
already gave you a small peepee in
hawaii he doesn't like your meme in
friday sweet pewdiepie too it's time for
the small
peepee cutter dude i gotta brand it i
gotta brine it up
i almost died
[Laughter]
i [ __ ] found this cinnamon show can
someone really just saw a shoe and was
like that's ken
best meme i've seen all week well done
no pewdiepie's editor
markiplier's editor hell yeah mark i
love you man
dude come on cy let's high five let's do
it
let's get inside
i get this meme now i've seen the movie
it's all coming together
squirrel squirrel squeaky squeaky
there's nothing you can't do
april 2021 april 2020
nice very good you very good for
i hope my electricity bill isn't high
this month the electricity bill oh damn
it's off that charts man
it's off the [ __ ] bell electricity
bill be
so loud very large i cannot stop
speaking uh sorry right is
hello peace you have a side windows
i have an assignment school where i have
to interview someone who works in an
industry i'm interested in so i figured
that i would interview my favorite i
don't know how to reach out so i figured
i read it would be a great place to ask
pleasure without them i read it
okay fine better get an a boy
okay i like that that's really sick cool
very cool love the colors
remade the leviathan interest pixel art
for this time
[Music]
oh that's sick that's sick
yeah nice well done
huge pp what are your superpowers again
i'm shy
it's a super power why why why how does
that work
no just buy the t-shirt you don't
understand do you want to playstation 5
or what
hey sing
hey hey i want to live there
happy place up boat when coco melon
viewers get older they'll unsubscribe
from pokemon and subscribe to ps meaning
victory is just a matter of time
that's facts and logic right there
upvote
that's sick amazing fan art this week i
love it that's a fluffy beard i do
appreciate it
oh i built another
sword portland spider-man's minecraft
bait that's sick
everything is just sick that's my entire
vocabulary but that's what it is
edgar who finally has free time to sleep
pewdiepie who just decided to make a
[Music]
video
i'm sorry he doesn't sleep that much
it's just like he knows i'm recording
videos
because he's like oh this is my time to
chill i can't bother him right again
oh you're so cute i'll let you get back
i'm sorry good boy
oh he fell could you see that
no if you if you die in hardcore please
don't add
in the title we won't surprise okay
that's a deal food's having 100 million
youtube subscribers me having more red
karma than me
no impossible
sorry i just felt like yelling that i
don't actually care
hey oh
i love the light that's so cool 4k and
8k
me watching 480p me watching on a
[ __ ] nintendo ds
i don't even know oh if you download the
video right
that takes effort i upload it's time to
go was that a good meme yes but these
kids ruined you
up vote all right this one gets to pass
because it's true
whoa whoa whoa whoa hell yeah
yeah i will definitely wear these
fuckeroonies upva
that's it that's all i got we receive
videos with better quality
memes with better quality oh that's fair
that's fair shake on
come on bros come on bros give it a
shakeroomy come on
what do you say what do you say
come on shake on it no
you can come back just let me know
whenever i'm here
you have my number feel free to call
back at any time
some things never change i think i know
where this is yeah there it is
oh beautiful
i saw you being born and i saw you die
[Music]
this is so sad puppet gloria died 50
times over
how many more times would she suffer the
four horsemen of pewdiepie
to the high beauty cry pity psy
pewdiepie how heavy is the 10 kilo one
good one oh yeah i saw this the
billboard is still
up i was on that street when i was
in that time when it came up with
toronto i thought montreal for some
reason
i can't believe i didn't see it i bet i
walked past
it dude it's crazy clicks on pewd's old
live stream i'm afraid it's members only
actually i left up the before your ice
stream just because i thought the game
was so good and i wanted you guys to
check it out
i really recommend it it's been a while
since i played a game i genuinely
enjoyed from start to finish so
before your eyes i recommend it if you
have an hour and 40 minutes
it's really good check out the game
yourself it's really fun i hate
youtubers who give away stuff
i'm gonna give you a thousand bucks if
you're ready to pretend you didn't saw
that oh
[ __ ] this brought up some controversy
well i know i have the right opinion
i don't even know why i'm discussing it
like giving away
stuff at the beginning of a video in
exchange for likes and subs
to me you're just buying those things
it's not a way to be nice to your fans
that's how people like to pretend it is
i'm so nice to my fans look i'm giving i
want to give it back to you
if you wanted to do that you could just
do that without asking for anything in
return
isn't that the point of giving something
back if you're giving something back
why are you asking for something right
on second thing there's no way to
get a random subscriber unless you're
literally just scrolling through
comments right
and all right put it on this way if
you're in a family and you're giving
back to your family but you only give
something to your sister then you're not
really giving back to
it's not really fair put that in
perspective of a million millions of
people
it's not fair at all it's not giving
back anything
at least mr beast to his credit makes
interesting content out of the fact that
he's giving away stuff
that's why he's so able to be so
successful because he
yeah he makes good content out of it
it's not just i need the algorithm to
like this video more so we're just going
to do a giveaway at the start of it
because i'm so nice to my fans like
that's [ __ ]
anyone who's a youtuber knows that it's
[ __ ] you're either stum
dumb or stum yeah you're either some or
delusional
if you think otherwise so no i wasn't
dawning on mr beats
i'm just sick of seeing giveaways at the
start of videos because it's [ __ ]
i receive meme review hosted by rick
ashley
you receive 10 million likes on the
video wow
i receive a bunch of growth and money
you receive nothing because no one wins
anything in giveaways get out of here
yeah that's right girls you like my
automatic have i told you guys
about my automatic sorting system ass
acronym
i would love to make this happen at some
point guys we just played through the
entire game i
i don't know but yeah that's it for this
week's
repair
[Music]
subscribe like you will get nothing in
return
that's the deal leo take it or leave it
it's not a threat
okay bye bye